Long ago, an everlasting being called the Sakura Dragon took root in Ashina's lands
From it, flowed various forms of immortality
Powers that would go on to corrupt the lives of men
One of these was the Dragon's heritage,
A direct line to the dragons undying blood.
And from that blood came the rejuvenating waters
Which was a bewitching force that grants great resilience to one's flesh
However, this power was never meant for Japan and from these gifts stemmed infestations and rot
Leading many, like Kuro, a divine heir, to ponder whether this power was a blessing or a curse.
So, atop Ashina castle, our goal becomes to sever this immortality and
what better weapon for this task than the crimson mortal blade?
This is one of two weapons in this world that's capable of wounding immortal beings
And once we ascend to the dragon's realm with this sword
We can rebuke its power
The crimson mortal blades true name, after all, is the Gracious Gift of Tears
And, by making the dragon cry, we reject its gift of everlasting life.
Sekiro: "Where is this mortal blade?"
Isshin Ashina: "I've heard it's held in the Senpou Temple.
The gates to that temple are closed now, though.
Who knows what those degenerates are doing, shut away up there in the mountains."
Senpou temple was once a place dedicated to Buddhist teachings.
These were teachings of selflessness, of death, and of rebirth.
However,
Divine Child: "Those of the Senpou temple have strayed from Buddhist teachings.
They have abandoned their faith,
Seduced by a search for immortality."
And since you are now considered an immortal being
Divine Child: "Should you be captured there is no telling what would become of you,
you would do well to return the way you came."
Despite being these rotting degenerates infested with immortal centipedes
The monks may not be as evil as they're being portrayed, but we'll get to that later
The first monks you fight bite down on sugars to enhance their strength
Which should be a strategy that's very familiar to you
If you've been using these sugars that you find scattered across all of Ashina
And their  placement around the world is actually very intentional
For, in an effort, to curry favor with the Ashina
Senpou monks effectively bribed the Ashina with candy
They spread these sugars across all of these lands in honor of Ashina's military heroes
Gokan, and even Ako, Ungo, or Yashariku are statued as we first enter Senpou
These men once fought for their country, but they all became corrupted.
Turning into the headless monsters that you find throughout your travels
Ungo, for example, lost his mind in defense of the state and he was beheaded, sinking to the bottom of a  moat
And since these sugar blessings are coming from such tormented creatures
You kind of have to wonder at what cost to us, or them, are these blessings being imparted?
And, you know, while we never really do get a chance to explore Senpou temple's "candy" factory
The monks themselves use these sugars really liberally
They use every single one of them except Yashariku actually,
this candy in particular puts you closer to death which made it forbidden to the monks of the temple
Yet, they had no problem distributing it far and wide in the name of donations towards their costly undying research
So these sugars brought them wealth and they brought them favor with the Ashina
And this focus on wealth in particular actually aligns with another tool of theirs, The Golden Vortex
It's an upgraded version of their large fan, which forces enemies to drop items and money
which are to be considered donations
And it's all ironic really
Considering the words of their founder,
These are the words of the high priest and they were ideals that were upheld
With the tenacious mastery of martial arts
These martial arts culminated in the Senpou esoteric texts
A tome that contains skills that are both martial arts and prayers
Weighted strikes that purge the self of worldly desire for
Without strength, one cannot defeat the enemies of Buddha and as we know there's at least one undying enemy of Buddha
Occupying a Buddhist temple in-game.
Eventually, however, this ideology decayed and festered
For the Senpou temple was seized by an obsession with undeath and their martial arts that were once used for virtue
Became used in the pursuit of immortality instead
There's even a curious statue sitting before their esoteric text that is consumed by flame
It's left half blackened and burned and if you finish the game
You'll know that this could be a sign of Shura a demon that appears in the bodies of those who have lost all virtue
This is a Myoo statue and these statues represented guardians of buddhist law
So it being so badly damaged is wholly
representative of the degradation of Senpou's brand of Buddhism.
This fall from grace has a lot to do with
Senpou's experimentation with the rejuvenating waters
which, as we mentioned earlier, is a legendary source of immortality and
it flows from the dragon's blood. We talked about Isshin in the last video on the first half of Sekiro that you watched and
He was a legendary figure who established Ashina as the dominant force in the land
we spoke of how he hates the rats from the interior ministry who are preparing to invade his land but curiously
He also considers these short assassins to be rats, as they spy on behalf of Senpou Temple.
Soldiers of Ashina: "It seems Isshin's illness is indeed grave."
"The land of Ashina will not last much longer"
"Even with Genichiro on our side"
Here the Senpou assassins spy on Isshin, ruminating on how the land of the Ashina is doomed
even with Genichiro on their side
Senpou is part of Ashina after all and its monks are
Equally screwed if the interior ministry invades them all
Especially since the interior ministry actually fears the Waters of Rejuvenation and Senpou temple has been experimenting
Successfully with the Waters of Rejuvenation for years. They have a lot to lose if Ashina goes down
talking more about these short assassins
They were originally hired to guard Senpou temple but inevitably, they became an extension
of the monks will in their quest for undeath. Their mission became to kidnap children
So that the Senpou monks could experiment on them with the Waters of rejuvenation.
So circling back around to Isshin. It's no wonder that he considers these assassins to be rats and degenerates
in fact knowledge of these experiments on children could explain why Isshin
Supports our quest to sever Kuro's immortality and why he's so disappointed
in Genichiro's use of the rejuvenating waters since his grandson Genichiro actually sided with the
degenerates of Senpou. In fact, there's evidence to suggest that Genichiro was actually
Encouraging even more research on the rejuvenating waters through Dosaku who you would have seen
Experimenting with them on Ashina's behalf in the abandoned dungeon
This place is right outside of Senpou temple and Dosaku wears a garb. That's actually
Identical to that of the bomb-thrower monks, in addition he fights with their martial arts
cementing the connection between the two places and
Considering this man was an ex disciple of Dogen who is another important character
I wouldn't be surprised if Dogen was also involved with experiments on the rejuvenating children as well
Dotting the hills of Mt. Kongo are hundreds of little statues that are accompanied by red and white pinwheels
these were offered in fond remembrance for the children that the monks sacrificed in their experiments with immortality and
At least one of these children is likely named
Armored Warrior: "Robertttt"
You might have heard of him round and round all their little pinwheels spin and yet the children are still right here
Kotaro: "The spinning, spinning red and white flowers. Only one pure, white flower."
And of all the children only one child survived the ritual
Battlefield Memorial Mob: "It was by a hair's breadth, but mercifully
She survived. Oh, she must have suffered greatly
you'd best treat her kindly."
This member of the Memorial mob still remembers the event and it makes sense, right?
Because where you find the departed, you will find the memorial mob .Curiously though, when he
Contracts dragon rot. He actually draws a parallel to what the children went through during the experiment
Battlefield Memorial Mob: "Divine children, forgive me."
Sekiro: "What's wrong with you?"
Battlefield Memorial Mob: "Buddha's Just in righteous punishment.
I had no idea the divine children were suffering so badly.
I see now. I must make an offering."
He feels guilty
But none should feel more guilt than those who are directly responsible
Master of the Senpou Temple: "Children of the rejuvenating waters.
Forgive me, that child
She's the only one left. She must be lonely
Trapped in that room by herself...
So you're the one who works for the divine heir of the Dragon's Blood?"
Sekiro: "That's right."
Master of Senpou Temple: "The divine heir is truly exalted, but exalted or not, man is still man.
I'm so foolish that I didn't understand that myself.
Don't, don't leave your divine heir on his own.
Leave! It's too late to regret once you've already lost them."
This man is a high-ranking priest as he claims to be at fault for the divine child's confinement
Furthermore, he's proof that the monks knew that their experiment was successful
But, ironically, it also seems like it's impossible for them to reach the realm where she resides
Master of Senpou Temple: "It's my fault,
the child,
She's confined within the inner sanctum.
It's impossible to see her now."
Why? Well, this is just speculation. But my theory is that Buddha himself
Protects the realm where the divine child resides because this space that she's at lies past the illusory halls
This is a realm protected by the folding screen monkeys
Beings that are said to occupy a space between life and death
These guys are a play on a proverb that you've probably heard- see no evil, hear no evil, speak no evil.
This is a famous proverb of Buddhist tradition
And there's even an invisible fourth monkey who was a reference to the 'do no evil'
Principle then they often leave out when they're talking about this legend. This to me
Is evidence that the Senpou monks turned a blind eye, a deaf ear, a mute voice
Upon their sinful path to enlightenment and it's likely to me that this bossfight
represents that fact
There exists a prosthetic in Sekiro
Called the large fan which allows you to spirit people away
All of the monks of Senpou temple were actually spirited away once before, that's why they're here
But if you spirit them away again
Rumors say they'll disappear forever
Unless of course,
they're Kotaro, a kind Senpou monk or unless they're the other monk here in the Illusory Halls, who seems
legitimately set on achieving nirvana. The fact that these two
Wholesome, legitimate monks are the only beings that were actually able to reach these halls when they're spirited away twice
plays into my belief that Buddha is perhaps
Protecting this realm from the infested.
Illusory Hall Monk: "By the way, there was once someone who, like you,
was on a mission. I believe he chased the monkeys for a while, but
Everything here eventually went silent."
This someone is almost certainly Genichiro,
he's a man with friendly links to Senpou temple, a man who is looking for the mortal blade and
He's someone who would have found it impossible to catch the monkeys since he doesn't have the same talents that we have
It's almost as if this was meant to be solved by us
Divine Child: "Please forgive them
They only sought to keep me hidden
However, it seems it was not meant to be
Close your eyes
Let us meet at the Inner Sanctum."
Here, the Divine Child of the Rejuvenating Waters parts you finally with the Mortal Blade.
Which you're able to draw thanks to your resurrective powers.
Sekiro: "I accept it's power."
Kuro: "Wolf...
That sword on your back
Is it the sword that can kill those who cannot die?"
Sekiro: "Yes.
It was given to me by the Divine Child of the Rejuvenating Waters at Senpou Temple."
Kuro: "The Divine Child of the Rejuvenating Waters?"
Sekiro: "The monks at Senpou Temple abandoned the ways of their faith in pursuit of immortality,
the result is those who have false dragon's heritage known as the divine children of the Rejuvenating Waters."
Kuro: " A false dragon's heritage...
I never would have thought... wait
divine children?"
Sekiro: "Yes. Many were created but only one survived."
Kuro: "Further proof of the corruption this power brings to man, the ties of immortality must be severed."
Sekiro: "Yes my lord."
Now that you have the gracious gift of Tears
We can actually acquire the Dragon's tears and sever immortality. Interestingly, though
We are not the first to seek the Crimson mortal blade with immortal severance in mind many years ago
There was a woman named Tomoe and a divine heir named Takeru
Who tried to do the same. Tomoe's note reads
what she's describing
is the purification ending, where the oathbound commits sudoku (very funny) restoring the divine heir's mortality
and the humanity. She goes on to write
The high priest is central to everything in Senpou. He was the founder of this temple
So we need to figure out what his motivations were
For creating the divine child, for starting this temple, for hiding away the Mortal Blade and for creating
the divine children. We find him dressed all in blue, his corpse sequestered away in a cave
and instead of immortal severance
Which Tomoe wanted, the high priest wanted a different ending.
Turns out he was actually gunning for the Dragon's return ending which he must have looked up on a wiki or something because that shit's
Complicated, but to this end and for this dragon's return ending he outlined his journey in two sacred
Scriptures. The first text that describes his journey is Holy Chapter: Infested.
Depending on when you arrive here,
it's either in the hands of the regretful monk outside the Halls of Illusion or
It's thrown to the bottom of the lake in disgust. It lays out a founding principle for Senpou temple
That their journey is to spend an eternity
Musing on why they cannot die
The text is from the perspective of the High Priest and it reads:
This text reveals a
potentially major twist in Senpou Temple's law. It reveals that their founding principle isn't
necessarily to acquire immortality
After all the monks already assumed they were immortal from the centipedes.
No, Instead their founding goal was to understand their infestation, something the high priest considered enlightenment.
Although, whether it is enlightenment and whether the path to that enlightenment was justified
That is another story
But he believed that the Avenue to this enlightenment was the creation of a divine child of the Rejuvenating Waters
and they abandoned all virtue and ethics while chasing that creation,
and when you give the divine child this text it explains to her why she was created
Sekiro: "I was told to give this to you."
Divine Child: "Thank you. I will accept it..."
Sekiro: "What's wrong?"
Divine Child: "I, I still cannot help but detest them."
In the end though
The information within does set her on a path to the dragon's return
Divine Child: There is something I would like to discuss. I believe we should aim not to sever the dragon's heritage
But instead to return it to its rightful place."
Sekiro: "Return the dragon's blood?"
Divine Child: "That's right.
The dragon's heritage was set free from its homeland and it drifted here to Japan
Its power was never meant for this land
Until something is done
it will continue to corrupt the lives of those who encounter it, the dragon's heritage and those
Connected to it.
It is only right that they return home
to the west
to the birthplace of the divine dragon
However, there is one problem. I am unsure of the exact destination."
Sekiro: "Who would know?
Divine Child: "Perhaps the high priest of Senpou Temple."
Sekiro: "And he is?"
Divine Child: "He's the founder of Senpou Temple.
I wonder how old he actually is. He has secluded himself in a five-story pagoda
Past the narrow cave not far from here...
Shinobi of the Divine heir."
Sekiro: "Yes?"
Divine Child: "This path differs from that of the one to sever
Immortality. I do not wish to force my opinion upon you. Should you wish to return the dragon's heritage
Then prehaps you should seek out the High Senpou Priest."
The infested chapter speaks of his undying journey towards understanding why he cannot die. And the second chapter :
"Dragon's return" lays out his conclusions. it reads :
The serpentine fruits mentioned, are the dried and fresh hearts of the Serpent's of the sunken Valley
And Senpou actually has a lot of pre-existing links with the snakes and with the valley that are really easy to miss
however,
discussions surrounding the snakes will
Continue in the 'sunken Valley' episode and will go deeper into the Dragon's return
I think in the endings video. Remember to subscribe and ring the notification bell so you don't miss out by the way
It's coming soon. I want to leave you on a really important topic, the infested, the centipedes. You probably thought I'd mentioned them earlier
They're so core to Senpou Temple and yet I mentioned them last because just like the monks and their motivation,
We don't really have enough information on them yet, in my opinion, to draw guaranteed conclusions.
what we do know is that the centipedes are found within Hanbei, the Senpou monks, the guardian ape and the
Corrupted monk and in all of these examples the hosts actually have a pretty symbiotic relationship with the centipede
They're able to carry on their goals while infested whether it be defending a bridge
meditating on undeath or
Just cultivating a flower to give to a mate
The centipede is more than happy to stay in the body for a ridiculous amount of time. And that might be their goal
we'll get to that later but
Assuming that the rejuvenating waters and the fountainhead waters are the same thing
then these waters are actually what all the infested have in common the guardian ape resides in a valley where the fountain
headwaters pool deeply the corrupted monk guards the fountainhead palace
And could also have linked the Senpou monks who themselves have studied the waters for an age. To me
It makes a lot of sense that the centipedes come from these waters after all,
the waters stem from the Dragons heritage and the Dragons heritage, too
Has its own form of stagnation in the form of dragon rot
Which eats away at one's lifeforce the centipedes mirror that stagnation in the waters of rejuvenation
Sealing it for me is that there is actually one more place that the centipedes appear
It's very hard to find but deep below Fountainhead lake
Surrounding the corpse of a giant carp are tens of luminescent centipedes
Which might mean that they infest the very source of the rejuvenating waters
interestingly
giant carp in Sekiro are supposedly everlasting and have goals of becoming a dragon and
the fact that some centipedes have stripped away an immortal corpse is
Curious to say the least. In addition, there are multiple Japanese legends that link centipedes and Dragons
But those are tales for another time for all their mentions about centipedes making the infested
Immortal, they might actually not for, in the cave by the five-tier pagoda,
we find the high priest and his peers as
still and as dead as the centipedes that rest upon them. The nature of the High Priest's undeath is
By far the most intriguing part of Senpou temple. Did he know when he was going to die?
Is this why he and his peers hid away in a cave
So no one would find out? Did the centipede leave their bodies once it was fully grown?
Does it have some objective beyond this place? Where did it go? And
also, how did this guy discover so much about the Dragon's return and what was his relationship like with the
Divine child? She knows about him somehow after all. There's a lot of questions that I could speculate on for hours
But this has gone too long already. I'm curious though, as always. What do you think?
I've actually decided to split the majority of Sekiro's story into four parts now and I'm doing this for a few reasons
partly because it allows me to go into way more detail as you can probably tell from this episode and
Partly because, hey I get to Commission a bunch of incredible art for every single episode
So that makes me happy. If you want to access all my notes
Or if you want full-sized
exclusive wallpapers that you see featured on these thumbnails then check out our patreon or
Just subscribe with twitch prime over on Twitch
The next few weeks are all about the lore. So stay tuned and I'll hash all over now